a columbus ohio police officer who
killed a black man a week ago
has been fired adam coy was found at
fault in a disciplinary hearing
yesterday for not giving aid to the man
he shot
47-year-old andre hill died in a local
hospital
the city issued a statement saying in
part coy's actions do not live
up to the oath of a columbus police
officer hill's family and their attorney
told us the firing
is the first step in getting justice
it's not fair that there's so many
procedures
when it's clearly on video the whole
world sees it
they're all murderers speaking out about
the black men and women killed by police
before her father andre hill
carissa hill says her family is not the
same since former columbus police
officer adam coye
shot her dad three days before christmas
according to police coy a 17-year
veteran and another officer
were responding to a non-emergency call
regarding a car that had been running on
and off in front of a house
body camera footage released by the city
shows hill walking out of a garage
holding a cell phone in one hand before
being shot by coy
i feel like if that cop would have gave
my dad a chance he'd still be here
both officers did not activate their
body cameras prior to the shooting
but an automatic record feature captured
60 seconds of video before and leading
up to the shooting
hands out to the side now hill also went
more than
six minutes without any aid after being
shot a violation of departmental policy
hill's sister michelle harrison i
believe that he
possibly could have been saved if they
would have went and applied
pressure and and
automatically george floyd was supposed
to be the turning point
where we saw these killers
come down according to records since the
day after george
floyd's death back in may more than 100
black people have been killed by the
police
and what is so ironic
is the fact that andre hill was one of
the black lives matter shirt
that had just george hart on when he was
shot
and killed by these police officers
and the police chief there in columbus
adding that when he became the chief
he wanted the core values to include
accountability